>>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS JUST
IN TO CNN.
TRULY DRAMATIC VIDEO, A
HELICOPTER CRASHING TO THE
OCEAN JUST FEET AWAY FROM
PEOPLE.
THERE IS OFF THE SHORE OF MIAMI
BEACH.
POLICE SAY TWO PEOPLE WERE TAKEN
TO THE HOSPITAL, THREE WERE ON
BOARD.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST MARY
SCHIABO, FORMER INSPECTOR GERM
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
INCREDIBLE VIDEO.
FOR THOSE OF WHITE HOUSE DON'T
UNDERSTAND -- OF US WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMIBS AT PLAY,
DOES ANYTHING STAND OUT FROM
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, HELICOPTERS, EVERYBODY
WANTS A HELICOPTER BECAUSE THEY
GO UP AND DOWN, BUT THIS ONE WAS
TRAVELING IN A DOWNWARD
TRAJECTORY, MUCH LIKE A PLANE.
AND THAT GIVES US A CLUE THAT IT
APPEARS THEY WERE LOSING POWER
IN THE ENGINE AND WERE DOING
WHAT'S CALMED AUTO ROTATION TO
THE GROUND.
WHEN A HELICOPTER ENGINE QUITS
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY JUST FALL
FROM THE SKY.
SO THERE WERE TWO IMPORTANT
THINGS AT WORK HERE.
ONE, THE PILOT WAS TRAINED AND
KNEW HOW TO DO IT, AND TWO, IT
WAS ABLE TO MAINTAIN SOME
CONTROL OF THAT AIRCRAFT BECAUSE
IT DOES APPEAR THAT, YOU KNOW,
ONCE YOU LOSE YOUR ENGINES, YOU
HAVE NOWHERE TO GO BUT HOPEFULLY
A CONTROLLED TRAJECTORY DOWN.
IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE COPTER
WAS ABLE TO STEER AWAY FROM THE
BEACH-GOERS, THE PEOPLE ON THE
BEACH.
SO TWO IMPORTANT POINTS.
YOU KNOW, THE PILOT WAS ABLE TO
MAINTAIN SOME SEMBLANCE OF
CONTROL AND GET IT DOWN WITHOUT
AN UPSET EVENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WERE
UPRIGHT WHEN THEY WENT TO THE
WATER.
>> EXTRAORDINARILY THANKFUL AND
LUCKY THEY AVOIDED BEACH-GOERS.
AT LEAST TO THIS MOMENT NO
DEATHS REPORTED.
IN A CASE, DOES THE WATER HELP
TO SOME DEGREE?
DO YOU BELIEVE THE PILOT MAY
HAVE BEEN, I THINK HE MIGHT,
HAVE BEEN AIMING FOR THE WATER
HERE INSTEAD OF THE LAND IF HE
WAS OF IN SOME SEMBLANCE OF
CONTROL?
>> YES, PILOTS OFTEN AIM FOR THE
WATER FOR, YOU KNOW, MORE THAN
ONE REASON.
IT DOESN'T USUALLY PROVIDE MUCH
OF A SOFT LANDING.
IT CAN HELP.
IT DEPENDS ON THE ALTITUDE FROM
WHICH YOU HAVE DESCENDED.
IF YOU'RE LITERALLY FALLING FROM
A HIGH ALTITUDE HITTING WATER IS
LIKE HITTING CEMENT.
BUT HERE BECAUSE THEY HAD SOME
AMOUNT OF -- MAINTAINED SOME
LEVEL OF CONTROL, YES, THE WATER
PROBABLY HELPED.
BUT IN SO MANY ACCIDENTS, PILOTS
HEAD TOWARD THE WATER TO SAVE
THE LIVES OF PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND.
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE ALSO JUST LEARNED THAT
THE FAA AND THE NATIONAL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY BOARD WILL
BE INVESTIGATING.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT AN
INVESTIGATION WOULD LOOK LIKE IN
AN ACCIDENT LIKE THIS.
>> WELL, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
THEY'RE GOING TO GRAB ALL OF THE
RECORDS -- INTERVIEW PEOPLE,
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
EYEWITNESSES, EAR WITNESSES.
IN THIS CASE, SINCE THE OCCUPANT
OF THE HELICOPTER SURVIVED, THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO INTERVIEW THEM.
SURPRISINGLY, THEY GO RIGHT TO
THE HOSPITAL.
THE NTSB LITERALLY WILL, A TEAM
WILL BE HEADED TO THE HOSPITAL
TO INTERVIEW THE OCCUPANTS AND
PRESUMABLY THE PILOT AND A
PASSENGER.
AND THEY DO TAKE A STATEMENT
FROM THEM RIGHT AWAY, FROM THE
BEACH-GOERS, ET CETERA.
THE SECOND THING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THEY GRAB ALL THE
LOG BOOKS AND MAINTENANCE
RECORDS.
LOG BOOKS OF THE PILOT, LOG
BOOKS OF THE AIRCRAFT, HAS A LOG
BOOK, TOO, LOG BOOKS OF ANY
RECENT MAINTENANCE, DISPATCH.
IF THIS HELICOPTER IS PART OF A
LARGER OPERATION, THEY'RE GOING
TO BE TALKING TO DISPATCH AS TO
WHAT THE HELICOPTER HAD BEEN
DOING ALL DAY, IF IT'S A
PRIVATELY OWNED HELICOPTER THEY
GO TO THE MAINTENANCE FACILITY
THAT WORKS ON THE HELICOPTER.
BUT INTERVIEWS, EYEWITNESS, EAR
WITNESS INTERVIEWS, AND GRABBING
ALL THE RECORDS ARE THE FIRST
TWO PRIORITIES.
THEN OF COURSE, THE HELICOPTER
ITSELF.
THEY CORDON OFF THE AREA.
BY LAW THE NTSB HAS PRIMARY
JURISDICTION, ALTHOUGH STATE AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT, THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE COAST GUARD.
THEY'LL BE HUGELY IMPORTANT.
THEY'RE SECURE THE AIRCRAFT.
THEN THE NTSB HAS THE RIGHTS TO
DO WHATEVER IT NEEDS TO DO TO
INVESTIGATE THAT AIRCRAFT.
THEY WILL -- THEY CAN TAKE THE
HELICOPTER APART IF IT'S STILL
INTACT.
THEY CAN LOOK AT ALL THE
COMPONENTS.
THEY CAN ASK THE MANUFACTURER,
FOR EXAMPLE, TO HELP.
BUT RIGHT NOW, IT'S A BIG EFFORT
TO GATHER ALL THE EVIDENCE,
INTERVIEWS, AND LOG BOOKS, AND
THE AIRCRAFT ITSELF.
>> AND CAN I JUST ASK -- I KEEP
LOOKING DOWN, LOOKING AT THE
VIDEO ON OUR SCREEN.
AND IT'S -- I'M BLOWN AWAY THAT
OBVIOUSLY THEY AVOIDED THE
SHORE, BUT THERE'S PEOPLE RIGHT
IN THE WATER AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
IS IT PURE LUCK IN THIS CASE
THAT THE BLADES AND OTHER
PORTION OF THE HELICOPTER DIDN'T
FLY OFF AND HIT SOMETHING OR
SOMEONE, OR IS IT SOMETHING
ABOUT THE DESIGN OR LANDING
ANGLE THE PILOT MIGHT BE GOING
FOR IN THIS CASE TO PREVENT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> WELL, AND SO MANY FACTORS --
HERE OBVIOUSLY THEY STILL HAD
THE BLADES FUNCTIONAL, AND THE
WAY THAT THEY HIT THE WATER,
YES, HAD THEY BEEN AT AN ANGLE,
THE WATER COULD HAVE EASILY
TAKEN OFF A BLADE OR CAUSED THE
AIRCRAFT ITSELF TO COME APART.
BUT IT DOES APPEAR THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET IT DOWN WITHOUT
THE BLADES COMING OFF.
NOW, YOU KNOW, BLADES COME OFF
FOR A LOT OF REASONS, BUT YOU
CAN SEE IN THE VIDEO THEY WERE
STILL INTACT.
BUT YOU KNOW, I'VE WORKED
ACCIDENTS WHERE PLANES HAVE
TRIED TO AIM FOR THE WATER OR
THE BEACH WHERE THE RESULT WAS
NOT SO FORTUNATE.
THERE WERE DEATHS ON THE BEACH,
DEATHS IN THE WATER, AND, YOU
KNOW, LOSSES IN THE AIRCRAFT.
SO YES, I THINK WITHOUT A DOUBT
THE -- THE PILOT AND THE
OCCUPANT HAD SOME BIT OF LUCK
WITH THEM, BUT JUST WATCHING THE
VIDEO -- AND THERE'S SO MUCH TO
LEARN BEYOND THAT, BUT JUST
SEEING THE VIDEO, IT DOES LOOK
LIKE THE PILOT HAD MAINTAINED
SOME CONTROL AND WAS TRYING TO
DO AN AUTO ROTATION LAND.
SO FORTUNATELY HAD SOME MEASURE
OF CONTROL STILL OVER THE
AIRCRAFT, WHERE IN MANY CASES
PILOTS DON'T.
>> AND TO THAT POINT, THERE'S SO
MUCH OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW.
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE OTHER THAN
THE VIDEO ITSELF.
HOW EXPERIENCED WOULD A PILOT
HAVE TO BE TO PULL OFF KIND OF A
MANEUVER LIKE THAT WITHOUT IT
TURNING DEADLY?
>> IT'S NOT NECESSARILY JUST
EXPERIENCE LEVEL, IT'S TRAINING.
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS HOW
YOU'VE BEEN TRAINED, WHERE YOU
GOT YOUR TRAINING, IF YOU'VE
REALLY DONE IT, REALLY BEEN
THROUGH THE TRAINING.
SO I WOULD SAY TO, ONE, HAVE THE
PRESENCE OF MIND AND TRAINING TO
DO THIS IS FIRST AND FOREMOST.
AND YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GET THIS
TRAINING IN YOUR HELICOPTER
TRAINING.
BUT IN AN EMERGENCY, IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU KNOW TO FALL
BACK ON, AND THE NTSB EMPHASIZES
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT
TRAINING FOR EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE IF YOU CAN
STILL CONTROL THE AIRCRAFT.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT THE PERSON
HAD THE NECESSARY TRAINING, KNEW
HOW TO USE THE TRAINING, AND IN
A CAREER YOU DON'T HAVE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO PRACTICE THIS.
YOU HOPE YOU DON'T ANYWAY,
BECAUSE IT'S AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION WHERE YOUR AIRCRAFT
HAS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM.
I MEAN, YOU LITERALLY HAVE THE
RISK OF LOSING THE PLANE AND THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE ON BOARD,
THE HELICOPTER AND THE LIVES OF
THE PEOPLE ON BOARD.
SO IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION, IT
GOES BACK TO TRAINING BECAUSE
YOU DON'T GET TO PRACTICE
EMERGENCIES VERY MUCH, THANK
HEAVENS.
>> YEAH.
NO, ABSOLUTELY, HOPE FOR THE
BEST.
BE PREPARED FOR THE WORST.
WE'LL KEEP YOU UPDATED AS WE